Computers aren't very good
at picking random numbers.
Every part of a computer is
designed to be predictable,
and to follow logical patterns.
You put the same numbers in,
you're going to get the same numbers out.
Which is a problem, because
all modern encryption,
including that padlock up in your browser
that tells you that you're safe,
all of that relies on big,
properly random numbers.
If you can somehow predict those numbers,
you can start breaking those locks.
Which is why I'm here,
at the headquarters of Cloudflare,
in San Francisco.
Cloudflare is a service that protects
websites and web services,
and sort of sits in front of them
as a gatekeeper.
Somewhere around 10% of the web
flows through Cloudflare's network.
Cloudflare was one of the first companies
to provide free SSL
encryption for websites.
So the connection between your web browser
and the website you're going to
is fully encrypted and
invisible for eavesdroppers
to be able to look at.
In short, these folks deal with a lot of
encrypted Internet traffic,
so they need a lot of random numbers.
It is possible to write code
that will simulate randomness,
and that's good enough for a lot of uses,
but in theory, those
numbers could be predicted.
They're just being generated by code,
so the servers here have to get their
randomness
from an external and
entirely unpredictable source.
A lot of home computers treat their own
users as sources of randomness,
tiny twitches of mouse movement,
the exact milliseconds between keystrokes,
or on a phone maybe even the
accelerometer or other sensors.
In all those cases, they generally discard
the bigger parts,
the bits that could just
be influenced by humans,
and go off the tiny little decimal places,
the bits that you couldn't
control precisely,
even if you wanted to.
But that sort of human
interaction is nowhere
near enough for an
operation on this scale,
hence lava lamps.
We videotape these lava lamps
and take the pictures and video,
and turn it into a stream of
random, unpredictable bytes.
And this unpredictable data is what we use
to help create the keys
that encrypt the traffic that
flows through Cloudflare's network.
This data is then fed
into our data centres
and then fed into the Linux kernel which
then uses it to help seed
random number generators
that are used to generate keys.
Every time that you take
a picture with a camera
there's going to be some sort of static,
some sort of noise.
So it's not only just where the bubbles
are flowing through the lava lamp,
it's the state of the air,
the ambient light,
every tiny change impacts
the stream of data.
A cryptographic hash function
is something that we use
where even if you have one static image
and one little bit changes,
it changes the entire stream.
So we use that to help
scatter the randomness
as much as possible.
We also collect randomness
around the world.
So in our London office,
we have this thing
called a chaotic pendulum.
It has three pieces and
it's unpredictable in
which way they twist and turn together.
We videotape that and feed it into our
randomness source, as well.
In our Singapore office, we
have a radioactive source
that we use to feed into the
randomness system, as well.
So this is not just some
stunt that we pulled,
it's actually being
fed into our real systems.
Whether anything in
the world is truly random
is arguably a question of
philosophy and not science.
Maybe everything is just
complicated clockwork.
But these lava lamps are so chaotic
that simulating that camera shot
with perfect pixel accuracy,
far enough ahead
to be useful
while figuring out everything else
those images are being put through,
it's roughly the same level of difficulty
as just brute-forcing the encryption in the first place.
And even if you could simulate all that,
you'd only have one piece of the puzzle.
These folks aren't the first to do this.
"Lavarand" was patented by a company called
Silicon Graphics in 1996,
but that only lasted a couple of years.
Now of course, there are less flashy and
more practical ways to
generate random numbers,
but then I wouldn't be here.
I would be at some
other company who'd gone and,
I don't know, pointed a camera at
a basket of kittens.
That'd be a bit higher
maintenance, though.